welcome angelina jolie hello you play
athena i do yes well we will talk to you
both so you vote for her
are you leaving us now i mean if you
want me to stay up
here here let's please
what place is
all right so i have a question for you
which actually both of you can answer
something that you have beautifully
talked about in interviews is having
your heart be a part of the projects
that you do and how that's important so
how did you connect athena what did you
find there and for you what did you find
in kingo that you personally connected
with
i think mine's gonna be easier
i was thinking like his insanity for you
he's like king goes so big and you're
actually quite humble so i actually
think you're
you know for me i i was yeah i just sort
of took parts of myself and and took
away
any sort of
worry he's the guy who's really
unworried it's i think being kingo is
pretty easy it's pretty fun what was it
i have you know i've wanted to talk to
you about athena for a long time after
watching the movie uh seeing you create
the character there i've become the
interviewer i know it was like all right
let's take over the back it's so it's
why don't you talk about that because i
want to hear it
see did you i thought i was trying to
avoid mine oh you want to avoid it we're
not going to let you out of the answer
she's
her my heart it's it's a hard one she's
she's
she has um
this is the first time i've talked about
it she has a post-traumatic stress
disorder she's a little uneven and i
think she's she's she's struggling with
a lot
and she's not sure she can
be what she needs to be she's not sure
she's strong enough she's not sure she
can still defend her family
well for both of you i'm curious you
know you both have played so many
different parts and you've had so many
superheroes or like you know
strong characters that you played is
there anything that really connected
with you about your character that you
really connected with the most or that
you learned about yourself in playing
this role
i guess it's that fragility that that
it's okay to be both
both fragile and uh
and and also strong it can it can go in
this it can be the same person
i i really you know saw that watching
angie work because you know i'm a very
verbal person the characters that play
are very verbal
and the character that she created she
conveys through her physicality so well
it really was inspiring and intimidating
for me to watch you really created this
person who says so much without really
having to use their words you know it
really was
it was really special to watch and then
to see it come together on screen it's
she's so good you tell we both are
obsessed with each other's characters
so we're hoping in the sequel we
actually think our characters are very
good like sparring partners i think so
because we're almost polar opposites
that's right but yet they're both a
little like out there so that's right i
think we would make a good time yeah
great pairing that's exactly right i
hope that kevin feige is listening to
this right now because you both have
some very good ideas
thank you
there you go kevin well that's what
happens when you have an academy
award-nominated screenwriter and academy
award winner you're both such wonderful
artists my last question is you know as
full artists for you with the script and
the writing and the way the story came
together
what um what did you most appreciate
about that and the themes that it has
family
we're a family and and it's um
and it's been too long coming this
family
yeah i think that's exactly right and
we're we're a global family you know we
look like the world for so long we've
seen superheroes that have looked like a
small percentage of the world this
superhero team looks like the world and
i also you know in the last year and a
half we've sort of learned that
we are on the same earth and we all
share the same problems like these
boundaries and stuff they're not as
important these borders are not as
important as
what we really have in common and this
movie
really gets to that it really gets to
the truth of the fact that we're all on
this rock together and we have to take
care of each other
that is a wonderful way to end this
interview thank you both so much for
stopping by talking live to the fans we
appreciate it have a wonderful time
tonight thank you thanks for coming